in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 9th, on which we commemorate
the Holy Apostle James, Son of Alphius. On the 9th of the month,
we celebrate the memory of the Holy Apostle James, the Son of Alphius.
Saint James, the Son of Alphius, was the brother of the evangelist Matthew, the publican.
As one of the choir of the twelve apostles, he too proclaimed the glad tidings to the pagans.
In his fiery zeal for God, he threw the altars of the idols to the ground.
By the grace of the Holy Spirit, he drove out evil spirits, healed the sick, and wrought many miracles.
He became known as the Divine Seed, because he sowed the seed of the divine word in the hearts of the people.
When he had proclaimed the good news around Gaza and Eleophenopolis,
he went about the world to share his love for Christ with all mankind.
In the end, he was arrested in the Egyptian town of Ostrasina.
He followed the example of the Savior unto death, for he was hanged on a cross,
and so gave up his soul to God.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.